your house is so lovely and is it
clematis you've got in the garden yes it
is yeah we're very lucky because we're
south-facing so we get a lot of Sun we
love it here
we're very happy hmm Jim tells me that
you've spent some time in Seville
yeah well I'm only only one year as an
exchange student so I did a semester at
the University but I met lots of friends
out there and I go there quite a lot
it's great it's very romantic place yeah
we decided to go on this kayaking canoe
little trip thing as we'd set off um you
have so good
straight away natural I was not so good
oh oh I was like as I gave up but um
there's one girl on her own as we turned
this corner she just like bashed into
you and smacked you in the face with I
don't like I fell into the water
Hey so bad oh god I got so dredged and
it was really cold that day in the world
afters we we stayed in the hotel and
balith II tensed it's one of your
favorite places oh yes it's it well it
was white is well we haven't been there
for a long time
no no nothing many years no
oh my god this way so fat look very
sweet though thank you so much for such
lovely lunch it was really great um
hopefully we'll see you when we're back
that'd be lovely thanks for this I'll
give it back to you on Friday
oh right thanks guys see you later bye
bye have a super time she seems pretty
nice yeah it's lovely well our Tim's
pretty nice too
you